[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
direction Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon à
4200 km de Paris Saint-Pierre port
mythique de la pêche à la morue jusqu'en
1992 de petits bateaux locaux vivent
maintenant d'autres
espèces
de Langlade pour deux heures de route à
peu près coupe à la ville coupe la bord
Yoann est plongeur de profession agathe
est volcanologue de formation à bord de
son voilier à la bourlingué sur tout le
Pacifique jusqu'en Alaska où elle a
appris la pêche c'était pas évident
qu'on va trouver un embarquement ici
déjà parce qu'il y a pas beaucoup de
bateaux en fait il y a une dizaine de
bateaux en pêche artisanal et souvent
c'est des équipages déjà constitués en
fait donc il y en a très peu qui
cherchent des Margaux et puis là j'ai
fait des belles rencontres
elle s'installe avec Yoann elle achète
un caseyeur de Terre-Neuve dont elle est
capitaine
il commence la saison de homard sans
casier à relever chaque jour un par un
après le crabe des neiges en hiver une
dizaine de bateaux de pêche artisanales
cible le homard à la belle saison
jusqu'à cette année il y avait très peu
de débouchés commerciaux sur l'archipel
c'est un bon produit c'est du bon le
même au goût ça c'est quand même
complètement différent en France ou
pas tout à fait le rouge et par rapport
à l'eau ou à ce qu'ils mangent dans le
coin mais c'est des bons
un petit qui est bon
directe à la société homard des îles
SP voilà belle qui permet maintenant au
pêcheurs découler leur production
localement sur l'archipel c'était vendu
sur Terre-Neuve fin de compte qu'ils
allaient pêcher le homard et ensuite
évacuer sur Terre-Neuve donc là on a
ramené à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon cette
économie qui est la vente de homard
l'exploitation du homard et aussi de la
vente local effectivement il y a ça
n'existait pas cette entreprise se
développe à l'exportation avec l'appui
de business France et ici c'est nos
maris americanus mais c'est pas dû
homard canadien ni américain c'est du
homard bien français quoi tri régulier
dans les bassins stockage dans de l'eau
de mer filtrée les installations sont
équipées pour expédier plusieurs
centaines de kilos chaque semaine le
principe c'est d'envoyer du homard
vivons frais de haute qualité par avion
donc c'est-à-dire sur la métropole sur
la Chine se rend compte cette semaine là
trois tonnes de homard vivant de
l'archipel ont décollé dans un avion
spécial vers le Canada destination
finale l'Asie
[Musique]